[Music]
people are really happy about it even I
would say non Trump fans that people are
really happy it's something that I'm
very proud of now with that being said I
want to get it done but I believe that
chairman Kim wants to get it done I
think we've done something very historic
already in one way but to me a success
is when it gets done the president
needed to disrupt the status quo and the
president has disrupted the status quo
he should be applauded for doing that
time will tell how this ends
chairman Kim achieved far more than
president Trump did this summit was much
more show than substance
what the Texans call all cattle no hat
no it's all hat no cattle so I don't
know if Senator Schumer lost the Texas
vote there with that phrase turn but all
had no cattle that was how the Democrats
described the North Korea summit here's
how the North Koreans described the day
after from state media showing his
understanding the president of the
United States expressed his willingness
to stop the us-south Korea joint
military exercises which the North
Korean side regards as provocation
during the times of North Korea u.s.
dialogue and also expressed his
willingness to provide security
guarantees to North Korea and lift
sanctions against it as the relationship
improves through dialogues and
negotiations now they say all kinds of
things but we thought we'd bring you
that the day after this summit what
about the fallout from it and what comes
next let's bring in our panel Steve Hays
editor-in-chief of the Weekly Standard
Molly Hemingway senior editor at the
Federalists and Eli Lake columnist for
Bloomberg view okay a lot of reaction
Molly on Capitol Hill some positive from
Republicans saying it needed you heard
the speaker there others saying they're
concerned that things are still on the
table and you hear the world reacting
that maybe Kim got everything you wanted
right you're hearing a lot of
pooh-poohing a lot of claims that Kim
got everything he wanted the fact is we
really don't know what will come out of
this deal we have a light framework all
of it will be worked out in the details
we will need to see substantive talks
they'll need to move quickly but it
could actually take many months many
years to achieve what we need to see
this
good start and it at worst it's a
neutral at best it's a very good start
but we have to work out a lot of
particulars what struck you in that
interview Steve I was struck by the
president once again saying that he
wants to get US troops home which I
think the North Koreans have been asking
for for a long time
looks to be a concession I was also
struck by his answer or probably better
phrased his audience around human rights
you pressed him on it twice the first
time he sort of dodged a question and
then found a way to praise Kim jong-eun
for his strength and his toughness the
second time he downplayed human rights
abuses in North Korea by saying yeah
basically everybody is guilty of some
things he could go through a long list
of nations that have those problems so I
was struck by that and the other parts
of it I think on the North Korea on the
denuclearization question itself was
consistent with what he heard he's
obviously very proud of himself
Eli well call me old-fashioned but I
like to believe America is beacon of
democracy and freedom and that when the
American elected president meets with
tyrants like Kim jong-eun there should
be at the very least refrain not to go
out of his way to basically lie about
the nature of this person and one point
he said another interview the North
Korean people loved Kim jong-un we know
that's not true
and in your interview what this kind of
thing we're saying well there's a lot of
bad people that do a lot of bad things
that is a sentiment that we normally
associate with Noam Chomsky and the hard
left that try to explain away and
rationalize the horrors of these
Stalinists like Kim jong-un
so as a general rule I don't really like
that kind of thing and of course it
would be great if you got a deal that
got rid of the nuclear and I'm not
saying you don't do diplomacy but I
don't think that Trump needed to go as
far as he did in his flattery I too wish
that President Trump had spoken against
the human rights abuses
he did speak it were told in the summit
behind closed doors sure I wish he would
speak more when we talked to him about
it now but it's also true that what he
is attempting to achieve right now is a
positive pitch he's trying to paint a
vision for Kim that he has a different
path that should be going and his goal
president Trump's goal is to make sure
that the people of Portland
aren't bombed by North Korea you have
this thing with neoconservatism
militarism fused with moral idealism
that seeks to achieve everything but
ends up accomplishing nothing and doing
so at a huge cost of blood and money and
so I think it's important that we
understand we have our national interest
here we want to keep from getting into a
nuclear war and we will hopefully
substantively deal with human rights
abuses which are serious and need to be
dealt with
that's not our first concern I may
respond an old neocon militarist by the
name of Ronald Reagan managed to
negotiate arms control agreements and
have a relationship with Soviet premiers
and still keep a laser-like focus on the
dissidents who were rotting in their
gulags and when the Soviet Union fell
that was something that many of those
former dissidents when they were free
remember they said it was something that
gave them hope I'm sorry but I hold out
that kind of expectation I'm not
expecting a negotiation where Kim
jong-un suddenly becomes a Jeffersonian
Democrat I understand that's not going
to happen but at the same time there's a
difference between that and having an
American president basically become in
some ways sort of you know part of the
dictators lie about his popularity with
his own pieces there's some of this that
is what if what if three summits down
the road it really does happen what if
the paradigm has shifted what if the
people who were looking at this as a
breakthrough are the right ones and the
ones that are very scared about the
potential are the wrong ones
yeah look that's possible anything's
possible right at this point but I think
you don't have to be a realist or a
so-called realist to recognize that it's
a problem for the president United
States to say things that aren't true
the president came back and tweeted that
North is no longer a nuclear threat that
I just landed long trip but everyone can
now feel much safer than the day I took
office there is no longer a nuclear
threat from North Korea meeting Kim
jong-un wasn't interesting a very
positive experience North Korea has
great potential for the future before
taking office people were assuming that
we were going to war with North Korea
President Obama said North Korea was our
biggest and most dangerous problem no
longer sleep well tonight we save a
fortune by not doing war games as long
as we are negotiating in good faith
which both sides are right
you listen on interventions pride
themselves on seeing the world as it is
that's the whole basis of their
philosophy that is not describing the
world as it is North Korea it remains a
first-order threat North Korea still has
nuclear weapons North Korea still has a
tyrant dictator as its leader they
present a threat to the United States
there's no getting around that and for
the president United States to come back
however proud he is of what he's done
and say that North Korea is no longer a
nuclear threat that's a problem four
months ago
going into this before the summer was
announced the position of the
administration was we won't even talk to
the North Koreans unless they take
concrete verifiable steps towards
denuclearization they just abandon that
which is its own concession and now four
months later with the only intervening
event being the signing of a document by
a dictator whose forebears have lied
about things for thirty years they're
now saying there's no more nuclear
threat I think you're just seeing a lot
of frustration that things have gone so
well a lot of people said that
everything that Donald Trump would was
doing would not go out would not go well
for him or for the United States his
bellicose tweeting supposedly had us on
the brink of nuclear war we all see what
happened in this summit we're not naive
it's not like the nuclear weapons
magically disappeared but we saw that we
have a very good start and if it doesn't
continue to go well we will have to
renegotiate still everyone underplay the
president said that the opposite this
what what we all know is that we had
very good talks that we have a good
framework that we have a good way to
proceed to disagree with the president's
surgery I know there is something about
taking him literally and taking him
figuratively and the tweets sure what
they mean and reading between Trump
language I mean there is all that that
you have to factor in but you're right
it's still a nuclear threat tonight
there's no doubt about it right yeah I
mean look we can decide that we don't
want to for our own reasons take
president Trump's words literally that
is not a luxury that the rest of the
world has and I guarantee you it's not
something that kim jeong-hoon is and it
puts Mike Pompeo in a box who's not the
very difficult tack task of constructing
a verification regime when the president
has already declared that there's no
longer a threat I would argue that the
American people have far less trouble
understanding President Trump than a
select few here in this town did I get
10 seconds well we'll see what happens
but I don't
the president should be taking a victory
lap look at President Obama's deal with
Syria and nuclear and chemical weapons
we saw how well that did all right
there you have